and I'm now going to introduce our next
speaker who is a man who has spent his
life champion open societies and the
rules-based order David Miliband the son
of Jewish refugees the former British
Foreign Secretary since 2013 the
president of the International Rescue
Committee one of the world's premier
humanitarian organizations you just
heard mr. Barron I saw you there in the
front row a man with a very different
worldview to yours what did you make of
it well two things struck me very
strongly listening to mr. bannon the
first is that he has absolutely no
answers to the problems that he rightly
identifies with the modern world and I
think we have to take very seriously the
grievances the inequalities the
insecurities that he is highlighting and
that he's speaking to and we have to
make sure that our answers our politics
of answers beats his politics of poison
and grievance and so the first plea I
would make to people is that we must
never allow ourselves whether we're
coming from the center-left which is my
position or the center-right don't let
us be lumped together as the defenders
of the status quo the great claim of
this so-called populist movement is that
it's trying to substitute itself from
defenders of the indefensible to
actually the attackers and the
insurgents and we shouldn't allow that
to happen but the second thing that
struck me listening to Bannon was in the
first part of your conversation and that
was when you asked him about European
history about the poisonous history of
what happens when leaders blame
foreigners for their own problems and I
thought back to the speech that mr.
bannon made in France in March of this
year when he spoke to the National Front
in France and he told them in words if
they call you xenophobes
if they call you racists if they call
you misogynist wear that as a quote
unquote badge of honor and that sent a
chill down my spine because of my family
history but also because of the country
that I come from I live and work in New
York I run an energy
that was founded by Albert Einstein but
I know that Albert Einstein was only in
New York because the politics of hate in
Germany was allowed to creep from the
edges from the margins to the mainstream
of German society and when Hitler was
elected in 1933 and I'm very wary of
comparisons with the 1930s I was brought
up not to default to that as an argument
but I think one of the lessons is that
we should never be complacent about that
kind of politics of poison and so I
think that it's very very important that
we sharpen our answers but we're also
ally it to a passion and a drive to
recognize the seriousness of the
challenge that exists how serious is it
that how big a risk does this politics
of poison very good phrase posed how
serious a risk does the world view
you're coming you're speaking someone
from a country or from the country as
well
the politics of brexit was not exactly
the politics of Steve Bannon but there
are some common elements and you and I
know that breaks it threatens to plague
the United Kingdom for the next 30 years
because of the social and economic and
political damage it does I think it's
very interesting however in Italy that
the the lead which was the Northern
League which had a very strong anti
European tint to it has moved from being
an anti European movement now to being
an anti migrant movement and the reason
is that the European Union remains
popular in Italy and if mr. bannon wants
to run the next European elections on
taking apart European healthcare and
copying the brilliance of American
healthcare I think he's gonna get a very
he's gonna get a very very strong answer
so I think we should take it seriously
the truth is its fragmenting European
politics is hitting 15 to 20 percent in
European countries except for Hungary
and Poland and there's a different story
that we can explore it if you like was I
think in those countries the attacks not
on the so called administrative stay but
the attacks on the free press the
attacks on the independent judiciary are
extremely serious and completely
contrary to European history as well as
Europe's future part of what we have to
then come up with is the liberal answer
if you will to the challenges that we
face and
right right ooh understand what mr.
balanced worldview was in the previous
conversation I think now though I want
to challenge you on what then do
liberals Social Democrats need to do to
restore the faith in in open markets of
free societies because clearly there is
a problem first of all you we have to
identify the problem and then tackle it
and I think that at the heart of the
malaise at the moment is three factors
some of which are within our control the
first is that the economic bargain has
broken down I mean the rent-seeking of
the top naught point 1/4 0.1% top 1% the
stagnation of wages in the middle is
undoubtedly a major not just a driver of
populism but it's a fault line in our
societies the bargain on which our
economic contract has been based has
been broken secondly the cultural
contract has been broken as well and you
see that in the debate that's being
raised on immigration but also on other
issues and we should come to the details
of that the third part though I confess
is a much more difficult one which is
the breakdown in the contract between if
you like the governors and the governed
the traditional basis of representative
politics in which people were elected
but also we're given the freedom to
exercise judgment that contract has
broken down and it's broken that you're
having sessions later about technology
in social media and I think there are
more fundamental issues there just one
thing I would like to say which is that
the the I'm not an economic determinist
but the current levels of growing
inequality post-crash as well as
pre-clear pre-crash immorally as well as
politically indefensible and this is
where actually liberals and Social
Democrats are not actually in the same
place I consider myself to be a social
democrat that means I actually believe
yes that it's important that individuals
have freedom from the incursions of the
state or the incursions of private
interests but if you're going to give
individuals freedom to achieve their
full potential then they need the power
of government on their side not just
breaking up monopolies not just taking
on antitrust but actually building the
equality of opportunity that is so vital
and the truth is that the political
economy of the center-left needs to be
renewed it's been the historic task
of social-democrats to rescue capitalism
from its own excesses that's what
happened with the New Deal in the 1930s
in many ways it happened with the war on
poverty in the 1960s and 70s zero we
have to renew our our political economy
in an absolutely fundamental way both
for those who are struggling at the
bottom and for those who are in the
middle but what does that translate into
translates into higher minimum wages it
translates into a bigger Earned Income
Tax Credit it translates into universal
health care which is in Europe remember
we have universal health care and so
that so it's a different model I think
the difficult questions are around the
following one how wages go up in the
middle in a service economy because
we're not lived with the truth is the
majority of jobs in the future are going
to be in the service economy not in a
magical and manufacturing economy and
how do you get wages up in the middle in
them you know secondly how can you
ensure that more employees have more of
a stake in the economic future of their
own firms and thirdly and very difficult
how do you make sure that the benefits
of a flexible economy don't become the
burdens of an exploitative economy all
very important this is but you are
raising questions if I was so small I
would be in politics so the
[Music]
let's get the questions right and let's
identify the route forward you're not I
would say you're not going to have an
answer you're not gonna I mean it's
interesting the Steve Bannon thinks and
this should be the news story that goes
out today
he thinks that nineteenth-century
America was the Golden Age for the
America now
never mind the sins of after the Civil
War and the the failures of
reconstruction but the idea that 19th
century American workers without trade
unions without support we're really the
represents the high point of our
aspirations I think it's really
something that needs to be challenged
very very fundamentally and I think that
we are we've got different national
issues there the the the Britain and
America I've got high employment many
continental European come to it and the
issue is wages many European economies
have high unemployment and so the issue
is how do you get them into work so
there's going to be national
particularity about it but I think that
the answer to this is to make is to
reclaim the economic ground and you know
I mentioned the cultural contract decide
fear that those of us who run NGOs or
who sit on the admire the economy's the
idea that we are in favor of unlimited
illegal immigration is a complete lie
and no one has ever stood on the
platform for unlimited legalism actually
you've not had a immigration bill in
this country since 1986 that's got
through and it's been blocked not by the
left but actually by the right so it's
important to take take it on a thing the
other area that I think it would be very
interested to hear your reaction to but
also where your ideas are is it refu the
whole question of refugees because you
run one of the biggest agencies that
deals with the refugees clearly
underpinning mr. Baran's worldview is in
the European context a sense as Viktor
Orban sees this as Muslim invaders what
do you think of the international
refugee system is facing considerable
challenges we're going to see more
pressure how do you fix it well the real
crisis is a crisis of civil wars around
the world we should be asking why are
that 25 million people displaced by
conflict and violence by unresolved Wars
whether in Yemen or in South Sudan or in
Syria so there's a crisis of diplomacy
which is my old businesses as foreign
minister in respect of refugees look for
centuries refugees have no rights and
were stateless and after the second
world war because of the trauma of the
Second World War
those people who are for whom it's not
safe to go home were given rights and
states were given responsibilities to
shield them the idea that it's the
inventors of that system the the Western
world that created rights for refugees
that is rolling back those rights and
the gentleman who mentioned the the
separation of families at the border was
absolutely right
to do so the idea that it's the
countries that wrote the UN Charter that
are now running away from its basic
norms is an absolute disgrace but it
also raises a wider point which I hope
we get a chance to to have a word about
um it's true that mr. Bannon wants to
roll back the rights of the refugees but
he also once sees that as part of a
wider rollback of international
cooperation now what's the truth about
the refugee crisis or the economic
crisis or international
security challenges the truth is the
problem is not that there's too little
International Cooperation W pom the
truth is not there there's too much
International Cooperation the truth is
there's too little the tragedy of the
European Union is not that the
management of the euro is over
centralized it's not centralized enough
the truth about the powers of the UN
High Commission on refugees is not that
they have too much power over
nation-states they don't have enough the
truth is about the global economic
system there isn't enough global
commitment to trade assistance for those
who are displaced by trade deals rather
than too much and so the image of this
over-mighty
international governing system is
completely out of kilter with the
reality of an interconnected world which
is under governed and under managed an
international level not over managed to
the detriment of the nation-state one
more which is in that context one area
that in the previous conversation we
spoke about a lot is China and the role
of China and how that shifts the
perspective of the international order
what is your answer to the worldview
that says we are in an inexorable
struggle with China and that's the
absolutely defining you know think of
our age well I think there are two
aspects to questions and on this I'll
have answers as well as the first is a
real category point because in mr.
bannon's narrative China is not just a
rising power it's a power that wants to
be a hegemonic power he compared it to
the thirties got an apocalyptic vision
of it and you've got to take a view is
did you take that view or in fact you
think that China is trying to increase
its own wealth its own strength but for
its own purposes not for global hegemony
purposes I'm very clear that China does
want to see itself at the center of the
world back if you like to the days of
the Middle Kingdom but it is not on a
path of world domination second and very
important point are we better off trying
to include China in the global system or
all which better off trying to exclude
China and challenge them to build their
own system I'm absolutely clear but the
worst thing we could do is incite the
Chinese to create their
parallel international system we want
there in the United Nations obviously
there at the on the UN Security Council
we want them in the system not outside
the system and I think it's really a
mystery is true that that is a is a bet
that we have taken for the last 50 20
years since China joined the WTO even
the expectation that China at the hope
the China would become more liberal and
it is not it has become more liberal
it's become more one is the question of
its liberalism at home and the second is
the question of its adherence to liberal
norms abroad I think in respect of the
foreign policy which includes the trade
we should blame ourselves when President
Obama did his pivot to Asia which was
absolutely the right thing to do he did
it on his own rather than with the
European Union rather than America and
the European you know presenting a
united front in negotiations with the
Chinese we've not been sufficiently
United and so I think the the category
area of the problem has not been the
entry of China into the WTO it's been
the question of how it's been handled
when it's been in the WTO I passed lots
of questions I'm sure they're gonna be
wolf in the floor yes gentlemen here's
second row in the middle my question is
related to China it's not so much that
they got into the WTO with not a clear
path of following our rules because when
you see American companies a European
companies going into China they're
forced to leave their technology behind
or when it's not stolen simply taken
away so how can you say that they're
playing with our rules when they're
actually using our rules to change the
system for their own benefit well just
to be clear I think they've used the
system to the maximum of their own
benefit what they haven't faced is a
united front on the other side and so I
think that it's a matter of what's been
the power play within the WTO and so I
think you're right to say that the
course they've pushed the boundaries
they push them as far as they'll go on
intellectual property and on a whole
range of other questions the issue is
what's been the sanction what's been the
pushback and the pushback has been
divided and fragmented not United and
effective next is there another question
yes then we'll move to here yes one more
from the middle there
so you talked about how we have to have
this pushback against China like why are
we opposed to tariffs then if at least
in the steep bannon's view that those
are push backs and sanctions against my
walk to tyrants what form does that
pushback take other than just talking
about and criticizing China because I
think that while in the short term the
taps are gonna hurt the Chinese in the
long term they're gonna hurt us more and
we're going what would you then do I
think it is an important question
because the the if we agreed that they
have not been playing by the rules and
if we agree that the steve madden
solution is raising tariffs hurt people
here as much as it more than anything
else what is the right approach the
right approach is to use all the tools
that exist within the multilateral every
European country and the United States
have strategic dialogue with the Chinese
in which the Chinese have got asks on a
table they want things and at the moment
they're getting things because we're
fragmented in the way we're negotiating
not United in the way we're negotiating
with them so whether it be on tech
whether it be on R&D
whether it be on inward investment
across the whole range we should be
using the full tools at our disposal and
remember the point about the Chinese
system at the moment is that they are
combining the virtues of stability which
they have it greater to a greater degree
than we do with the ability to plan for
the long term
and we are being cursed by fragmentation
and short termism and in that contest of
course they're going to be able to push
forward the next thing you're gonna find
is that they're making friends across
Africa and across Latin America are
gonna push back against us as well but
that's part of the retreat they see the
Chinese see their relationship with the
West as a whole economic political
cultural we see it in transactional
fragmented and short term as terms and
that's not working yes second row there
so we talked about economic inequality a
bit and Sweden where I'm from has had a
very strong welfare state originally but
lately inequality has grown the most
within all obesity countries within
Sweden and that is not due to a growing
gap in wages but in the growing gap
between capital gains and wages not
growing enough and your solution was to
have higher minimum wages and also to
have a strong middle class and
middle-class house tax subsidies but
what I'm seeing is that you're kind of
just kicking the ball down the alley
when you're doing that because of
technology you're going to have a lower
lower access to middle weight
middle-class jobs to jobs that are not
high technology jobs so how does a state
solve a crisis where people are feeling
left out with economy you're not going
to be able to solve that with the
traditional wealth for policies that we
had in the 50s and 60s
well I think it's a great it's a really
important point that you're making I'd
say a couple of things first of all
remember that the left out in Sweden I'm
not the 50 or 60 percent that Steve
Bannon was claiming for hungry there's
we don't want to minimize it with Sweden
Democrats got 17% of the vote in the
Swedish elections the mainstream parties
be they center right center left green
or otherwise got upwards of 80% of the
vote between them so remember many
people would trade what the Swedes
consider to be the challenges that
they've got today all the inequalities
that they've got today secondly I think
Sweden is an example where the speed of
the cultural change not between men and
women but the cultural change associated
with immigration has been very very
significant in in the last 20 years
Sweden has gone from having a very low
proportion of foreign-born population so
now one of the highest in Europe and
there's no question that's been part of
the political argument that's going on
there badly managed in the sense that
there has been very little encouragement
to integrate those new immigrants into
Swedish society yeah I mean particularly
with the admission of children and then
families who follow them I think the
third thing which I think you're raising
a really important point which is about
access to capital and it's about the way
in which the
this tax but it's also about the way in
which business creation takes place and
the way people are included in the
success of their own business and I
think that we've got I remember even ten
years ago at the time of the financial
crisis when I was still in government
the debate about a financial global
financial transactions tax which you
advocate in your editorial quite rightly
got stuck on the fact that the u.s.
never wanted to buy into a global system
and didn't know where the money was
going to go the Europeans got stuck
because a couple of European countries
didn't want to play into it I think at a
micro economic level the issue of how a
certain at this point earlier how a
service economy was that's where most
jobs are gonna be how a service economy
can deliver middle-class wages not just
minimum wages is an unresolved question
but if you're not going to upgrade it by
a negative income tax then you're gonna
have to find a way for us those who are
in word to pay more for the services
that we're getting we've got oh I've got
more time I was bad say we've got run
out of time luckily I think give more
time on the clock one more question yes
lady there forth great time question
about my day job and about refugees and
how this country can become a
humanitarian leader again well you
actually wanted to go back to your issue
on conflict and kind of resolution and
diplomacy as a way of resolving conflict
and potentially dealing with migration
and I kind of wanted to see your hear
your vision for that because it seems in
many cases diplomacy isn't working yeah
look I'm very scarred by the fact that
you know we've got six hundred people
working for the IRC in Syria we've got
400 people working in Yemen we've been
in Afghanistan since the 1970s and we've
got 700 staff still in Afghanistan and
I'm scarred by the fact that they are
more under threat as humanitarian
workers than they have been before we're
losing more of our workers and I'm
scarred by the fact that the needs are
growing faster than our ability to to
meet them and that's what makes me think
two things one the humanitarian system
does need to be reformed because
refugees are out of their own country
for an average of 17 years because
they're in urban areas not in Kansas we
got to change the way we do the response
to the symptom of the problem but then
to your point secondly the tools of
peacemaking were developed
wars between states what we're suffering
from around the world today why there
are 25 million refugees is not wars
between states its Wars within States
Syria Yemen South Sudan being the best
example now the response five or ten
years ago to this was to say look you've
got to recognize that these problems
have to be solved locally or regionally
so in the South Sudan example it was
let's give Africa the the East African
countries the responsibility of sorting
now they haven't been able to sort it
out
and so my to the extent that I have a
recipe on this it would be one you have
to internationalize the problem if the
big problem powers don't care then
you're not going to solve it secondly
the Syria shows if the big powers aren't
united you're certainly not going to
solve it thirdly and last point in all
of these conflicts you've got non-state
actors as well as state actors and the
extent to which they are inside the
system or not and inside of peace talks
or not this is issue in Yemen which is
very present in my mind at the moment is
absolutely core to whether or not you
can deliver the peace and the reason I
raised it is partly that it's a global
problem but also every meeting I do
where I talk about the work we're doing
on how we can do more people say yeah
but how are you gonna get to the root of
the problem and the root of the problem
and in the peacemaking that you do you
draw attention to I hate to bring this
conversation to net because it could
continue for a long time but we are
really out of time now we've had from
you I think a very different perspective
a perspective this is we haven't had
enough global cooperation we haven't had
enough cooperation between countries
quite the opposite to mr. bannon a lot
of food for thought and I'm going to now
hand over to my colleague Gary Epstein
who I hope will go to the other stage
there are media editor to continue the
next conversation David Miliband thank
you very much
[Applause]